[Música]
resiliencia
una vez lo estudie cuando estaba en la
universidad
pero la verdad que no me acuerdo de nada
lo que sí que puedo decir
es que hay un personaje
que en sí mismo lo explica
y os voy a contar su historia que es
mucho más interesante
un día
estando en mondoñedo iba de paseo por el
monte
así andan 22
y quería subir a lo alto entonces vas y
andando chas chas chas y de repente
empecé a sudar ya por aquí porque claro
iba cuesta arriba andando y de repente
escucho
para en seco
o sea que esta oreja que escucha un
monton icesi
y el sonido desapareció seguían dando
charlas
chas seguía cuesta arriba y ya empecé a
sudar también por este otro lado
y vuelvo a escuchar clarísimamente
[Música]
para en seco pero por el otro lado o sea
que esta otra oreja
y volvió a desaparecer el sonido que
extraño seguí andando pues había un
árbol
el único eucalipto que había en el monte
y baño cuesta arriba chas chas chas y de
nuevo esta vez muchísimo más claro que
las anteriores volví a escuchar
paren seco de nuevo con las dos orejas
identifique de dónde venía el sonido
detrás de ese único eucalipto
fui andando hasta él
me asomé mire para abajo y allí estaba
me miraba y hacía y yo lo vi y dije
y él me miró y dijo lo mire
y con estas manos lo cogí lo llevé a mi
pecho lo miré y dije ah y el hijo
y me lo llevé a casa lo desparasite
lo eduqué de comprar ropa me llevé a los
mejores colegios etcétera etcétera
etcétera y ahora viaja siempre conmigo
no os he dicho cómo se llama verdad
se llama rayo queréis conocerlo
rayo mira hay aquí un montón de gente
que quiere conocerte
en garray hombre que han hecho un
esfuerzo por venir
ahora yo
para poder
venga va
va a saludarlo
mayor
a ver rayo
venga sal
a
claro tenéis que decir todos
a ver
rayo
e
fuerte lanza para rayo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
m
ep3 efe
ppp vale para para para así
bueno este rayo rayo y yo somos grandes
amigos como ya sabéis nuestra historia
y rayos a va a hacer un montón de cosas
que yo he enseñado que si rayo
qué te parece si empezamos con el truco
de la banqueta bueno verás radio va a
hacer ahora un truco que consiste en
ponerse de pie sobre esta banqueta en
una sola pata
hoy
claro que necesita animación
e
atención atención que viene lo difícil
en una sola pata rayo encima de la
banqueta de una sola pata fuerte la
radio
muy bien rayito muy bien buen chico rayo
rayo medio
para sí
bueno pero no sólo eso porque rayo es
capaz de hacer muchas cosas masajes y
radio por ejemplo si yo ahora yo le digo
radio
plas
muy bien rayo rayo
si es verdad
al ser una innovación rayo jumper
champagne
salta
por ejemplo room
correcto
muy bien sin más y ahora si ahora llega
el momento de la verdad en el que rayo
va a demostrar y va a devolver todo ese
amor que yo he puesto en su educación en
su crianza habrá que si rayo y lo va a
demostrar dándome un beso en los morros
rayo
el beso nada más un rayo va a demostrar
todo ese amor que me tiene dando besos
rayo ven tú quieres cenar esta noche
si no hay beso escena
era una tontería ahora sí rayo para
demostrar ese gran amor que me tiene
a dar un besito en los morros
fuerte el aplauso a radio que me dio un
beso en los morros
[Aplausos]
creo que le voy a tener que cambiar el
pienso porque le duele un poquito el
aliento
o es que pasó algo extraño
no
bueno rayo adentro me quedo con esta
gente
para adentro sabéis que rayo es el único
perro que juega al revés que el resto de
los perros
os preguntaréis cómo juega un perro
verdad
pues es muy fácil
ay
[Música]
pero este parece pérez pérez pérez de
pvc plc rayo para yo no puedo ir para sí
ahora es cuando uno de vosotros este
ángel levantar y traer la pelota va rayo
no voy a elegir quién pero cualquiera
[Risas]
con el rayo no es así
rayo por fin puedes decir
[Música]
[Aplausos]
rayo por fin puede decir que una
eminencia que ha dado la pelota creo que
está súper satisfecho porque por regla
general tirar la pelota seis o siete
veces
no
rayo eso no aquí no hay
bueno vale pregunta rayo que si tenéis
fe
tenéis fe
pues no
que si creéis en los títeres
pero no
bueno esto va por cuenta de radio dice
que os va a bautizar m
muy bien rayos ya has hecho de las tuyas
bien
estarás contento no es bueno pues nada
hasta aquí llega la historia de radio
verdad que sí
cómo que no si ya no tenemos ningún
número más cuál
así la despedida que para despedir a
radio tiene que decir todos radio radio
hasta luego rayo
esto es lo que yo conozco por
resiliencia
estaba destinado a ir a la basura todas
las partes a los objetos de los que
estaba compuesto su historia era una
historia de pérdida estaba allí tirado
en el monte y superó todos los
inconvenientes y ustedes lo han visto
[Aplausos]